i feel  he is rather proud  and very charming  he is  mysterious but not obscure  and  his face is so bright with intelligence  what else  um  he's very beautiful obviously is he yes  but his natural modesty means he's  completely unaware of it i've met people  like that they're so rare yes perhaps i  could make a confession too yes but i  haven't made mine yet i'm sorry please  continue this man i love is a guard in  your regiment of course he is of course  in a sense that i interrupted please  continue  it's embarrassing to admit but i've  never actually spoken to him of your  love of anything  it was love at first sight the  thunderbolt it's madness fantastical and  yet it's absolutely  real  [Music]  you